Terry McCauley NBC rules analyst for
Sunday Night Football and also Notre
Dame games he will be in the booth
without Michaels and Cris Collinsworth
this Sunday night as the Cowboys face
the Texans Terry good morning thanks for
joining us and I want to start with the
clock the play clock on the field
because we saw a situation in the Kansas
City Denver game explain to me from an
officiating standpoint of what you're
supposed to see with the clock and when
the ball is snapped good morning Dan
great to be with you again so with the
play clock it's not first of all it's
not intended to be like a shot clock in
basketball it's not it's not a technical
application of a rule that they want
enforced every single time so
mechanically wait what does that mean
Terry that they don't want that means
well there are a lot of technical
violations that happen during the course
of a game that you just don't want
called you want warnings issued you want
you know you want it to be a little more
obvious that an errors there a thousand
getting been committed because just like
fans the league does not want a lot of
unnecessary flags so and delay of game
is one of them it's you know the clock
doesn't start instantly when like light
doesn't start instantly when the plays
over you know there's a one or two count
it's just a general guideline that we
want the ball snapped within about 40
seconds of the previous play so
mechanically you know they they
assignment to the back judge he's the
guy in the middle of the field on the
defensive side wait about thirty yards
from the ball right so he's watching the
play clock and I noticed in Denver it's
it's low so that helps him a little bit
so he's watching it it hits zero then he
goes to find the ball has the snapper
started moving the football at that
point if he it's clearly still on the
ground then he's gonna shut the game
down and throw a flag if the ball is
starting to move at about that time he's
gonna let it go and and what's
interesting about this this happens two
three four times I would say in just
about every football game yeah where
it's it's bang bang like that and it's
almost never
ever commented on because the subsequent
play doesn't really mean anything well
on Monday night the subsequent play
actually was a big place so now it
becomes a huge talking point though they
out you know Denver is outraged you know
the players are talking about it but
it's it this has been consistently for
enforced this way since I got in the
league in 98 and and I'm certainly way
before that this is not this is not
anything unusual at all did you hear
from the league office and they said
look guys don't call it unless it's
really you know egregious like is that
is that what the directive was
absolutely it is you want the ball to be
clearly on the ground when the eyes get
to the football from going from the play
clock in fact if you did it any other
way
if the back judge called it to
technically they would get downgraded
even though it was at zero at the
instant that that the ball you know that
then the ball was still on the ground if
they threw the flag too quickly and shut
the play down they would be downgraded
in that situation I don't understand
that like why why have a rule that you
can't enforce
I mean it's usually it's look you're
right it is loosely enforced because
it's not like the play clock I mean it's
not like the shot clock in basketball
it's it's it's a technical violation
just like you know lining up you know
illegal formations and and the defense
has a space mask just barely in the
neutral zone it's it's things that that
that you could call constantly
throughout the game but just just
frustrate fans coaches players officials
that don't need to be called unless it's
clearly obvious that a fouls been
committed but you know staying on that
theme then you can call holding on
everyone right okay you can't call
holding on every play if there's anyone
you know there is no world no there is
holding on every play because just
because a player grabs the opponent it
does not equate to a foul you
grab inside the frame for the entire
play I mean just two big handfuls of
Jersey the entire play and it's not a
foul so it can't be called every play it
does happen every time yes how often do
you have pass interference and you don't
call pass interference well that's
that's that's a whole other topic I mean
there they are
the defensive backs are really really
good at hiding and and and and our
officials are there officials are really
good at calling it but they do make
mistakes it is a very difficult call
probably one of the most difficult in
real time to make that instantaneous
judgment does the defender restrict the
receiver and and a foul should be called
we're talking to Terry McCauley NBC
rules analyst former official he works
for Sunday Night Football on NBC the
lowering your helmet Kareem hunt led
with his helmet any truck to Broncos
defender but he's a running back are we
going to enforce that rule from a from
an offensive standpoint where we
penalize them it doesn't seem like we're
really enforcing it at all anymore the
you know the guidance that went out
halfway through the preseason kind of
kind of led us down this path the the
intent was to get the the absolutely
major forcible punishing hit and by the
way I think Kareem does fall into that
and and the reason is he lowers his head
and he actually accelerates into the
defender and and it is it is exactly
what they want called for a foul however
I will tell you officials you know as
the seasons gone on they're getting
messages they're from from the office as
these plays are evaluated throughout the
course of the season and what I think
they're hearing is is that we would like
this called but we're not going to
downgrade you on it because it's a very
difficult call
we'll find during the week but until the
officials are evaluated on these plays
that ok this is going to affect my
postseason if I don't call this I don't
think you're gonna see very many of
these they put the words in bracing for
contact for runners yeah and I think I
think that's kind of a dog whistle two
officials that
runner you can always bail out and not
make a call by saying I felt in
real-time
he was bracing for contact but clearly
not what happened on this point what are
we looking at the officials with these
roughing the passer calls it feels like
they've been told to call it enforce it
and you don't want to get downgraded so
it feels like the officials went above
and beyond the call of duty or am I
reading too much into it
no I think that was that was absolutely
true in the first three weeks if I'm not
mistaken there were only four in week
week four yeah and I think three of them
were in one game and only one of the
four I believe was body weight which was
a clear and obvious foul in the San
Francisco Chargers game so I you know
it's tough to say after one week whether
you know it's because players have
adjusted although I do think that is the
case I see a lot of adjustment on
defensive players as they hit the
quarterbacks now or or if the referees
have have indeed backed off somewhat and
and and have a little more discretion or
a combination thereof are you told you
know explicitly protect the quarterback
is that yeah there's no question that is
the referees number-one priority it has
it was in 1998 in 2001 when I became a
referee and it continues into this year
there's no question that's their number
one priority is this for ratings well I
I think it's for you know and the NFL is
an entertainment business and the game
is better with the starting quarterbacks
in you've got 32 quarterbacks that are
extremely important most of them are the
franchise player of the team and and
that's who they want to stay in the game
some teams have really good backups as I
think we're seeing with CJ Beathard and
San Francisco has been pretty impressive
but not every team does and fans want to
see the offense they want to see the
starting quarterback the guy that's
that's really going to make their team
exciting and that's that's the way the
NFL is operating it feels like and I
know the quarterbacks you know Ben
Roethlisberger Aaron Rodgers hey we
don't like this rule here but then
Ben acts like he you know was knocked
down with a you know a lightning bolt
the other game when he got hit in the
helmet and he goes I may have played
that up a little bit
feels like if I'm a quarterback I can
publicly say and I don't want to be
treated differently but if I if I'm
trying to win a game I'm gonna work you
guys work the refs the entire time so
how do you differentiate between what is
real and what is not well you you have
to use your experience you know in real
time
do you see forcible contact do you see a
clear violation of the Spirit and the
intent of the rule and and what the
player does his reaction to that you you
pretty got a dismiss pretty much we got
to dismiss that and and and not make a
call on on you know get he faked it or
did he fall or did he you know Hollywood
it or whatever and just deal with the
action itself by what what happened what
the defender did to the quarterback and
and it's tough it is tough in real time
because you do see players and it's not
just the quarterback the receivers how
many times you seen him throw their
hands up have any time have you seen the
defensive lineman throw his hands up
because he thinks he's being held and
and trying to buy it every player does
it and it's just the officials job to
decide did it really happen or is he
trying to buy one the best acting
quarterback that you ever dealt with who
could really be put on a performance
there that you weren't quite sure I you
know I I want to say Jay Cutler might
have been in that in that in that mode
Phil Rivers might might might fall into
that category but really all of them all
of them do it I mean I and I say all of
them I I see let's put this way I've
seen everyone do it at least once
to be fair do refs want to do interviews
after the game no absolutely not
that is that is one of the worst ideas I
think I've ever heard in my life we want
you interviewed after the game would
make it would make for great
television no doubt you've been under
the microscope and have people talking
about you and complaining about you for
three hours and now we're gonna further
that by putting you under the spotlight
without having access to any video and
all you're going to do is is try to
justify defend what you've seen and what
you saw in real time and and you may or
may not be right so I don't think it
serves any purpose whatsoever from from
a being productive in explaining what's
what what's happening Terry you
mentioned the magic magic words it's
great for TV
we're in the entertainment business but
but the officials are not they're not
supposed to be the ones that that are
attacked and and that has to have to
make that make your story for you good
to visit with you safe travels to Dallas
and great to catch up with you again
Terry thank you for your time thanks for
having me Dan Terry McCauley NBC rules
analyst for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]